you spend your time on dumb [ __ ] you  know many people here have a one-hour  meeting that's really seven minutes you  know how many people here enjoy the  feeling of micromanaging they enjoy  because they get their self-esteem from  telling someone that works for them that  they do the thing better I'm serious  leave with that one repeat what I just  said to yourself you will find a  shitload more time to do things and I  want to remind everybody I have 1200  employees and every day when I brush my  teeth I look in the mirror and say  everything in your company is a hundred  percent your fault the people in here  that have 19 employees and want to blame  Sally you hired Sally